Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 is out and there have been a
ton of questions about Groot during the movie
Vin Diesel James Gunn have talked a lot about
the character and why he evolved so differently
from the original Groot in the first movie so
he didn't just go back to the exact same size
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos because Guardians of the Galaxy
3 just came out in theaters we're also still
doing the special giveaway for copies of the
Guardians of the Galaxy video game thanks to
the idos Marvel people for asking to sponsor
the giveaway the video game is a third person
story driven action-adventure Style game you
play as Peter Quill Star-Lord and are joined by
different members of the Guardians of the Galaxy
at different parts of the story the story picks
up a few years after the annihilation Conquest
storyline and Marvel Comics that was the story
where this particular roster of the Guardians
came together for the first time there were
some Easter eggs for that in the Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 movie The continuity of the game
borrows from both the comics and the Marvel movies
so his backstory is a little bit different in
the game the reason why he left Earth in the late
80s is a little bit different but he is still
from planet Earth in some of the characters that
you encounter in the game are characters that are
appearing for the first time in live action in The
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 movie the present day
of the game takes place in the early years of the
Guardians of the Galaxy team they've been together
for a little while but they do cover the events of
his backstory during the beginning the game does
have different outcomes based on the choices that
you make of Star-Lord throughout the story the
soundtrack is great it's closer to James Gunn
70s 80s music from the movies there is no DLC or
micro transactions it is a single player game and
it is available right now on all the major video
game platforms like the PlayStation Store Xbox
steam if you prefer PC gaming I'll put a link
for it up on screen and down in the description
below so be sure to check it out and I will pick
three giveaway winners randomly from the comments
within the next few days and announce the winner
during one of my Marvel videos next week careful
for spoilers for the movie if you haven't seen
it yet but at the end of the movie after the
main Guardians team goes their separate ways and
Rocket becomes their new captain forming a new
roster with with phylabel Adam Warlock as well
as blurp we see them on a foreign Planet getting
ready to save a group of townspeople literally
guarding the Galaxy Rocket says jokingly we
find out that enough time has passed since that
final moment of the original team saying goodbye
on nowhere like the small enough time Jump for a
group to grow again to his full adult form which
Vin Diesel is calling Alpha Groot about how Thor
will incorporate some of the Guardians of the
Galaxy which would be very interesting nobody
knows but maybe I shouldn't have said anything
um but I only have two words about that character
and it is Alpha group he's meant to be like the
gigachad version of himself the final boss form
however you want to think of it there were a lot
of jokes about this last year maybe even before
that too because Vin Diesel has been working on
the movie for so long he called him Alpha group
pretty early on and James Gunn responded to
it saying maybe he just means the most awesome
version of group like he was trying to deflect
like oh yeah he definitely gave away a spoiler now
he looks much closer to the size and strength of
the rest of the leaders of his race in the comics
the floor of Colossus they're called The Arbor
Masters like the most powerful members of his race
now he doesn't speak in the post-credits scene
rocket just wakes him up because he's been taking
a nap on the ground while they all wait for the
animals who were threatening the townspeople to
arrive because they all joked the job is very easy
like they don't have to worry too much about it
based on his size relative to the other Guardians
compared to before it looks like he's now at least
twice as large as he was earlier in the movie he's
way stronger than the original Groot was in the
first Guardians of the Galaxy movie I'll explain
the difference between this group in the original
group too he even looks like he might be a little
bit taller too mostly he's just way way stronger
there's some other minor differences in their
abilities too James Gunn was talking about now
that he's evolved again to the alpha group form
his powers are mostly the same what you saw during
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 he already demonstrated
a bunch of different abilities a lot of the toy
merchandise was calling him the Kaiju version of
Groot but I think that was mostly a reference
to the way that he was forming wings with his
body making himself super large using all the
limbs on his body like they were different arms
so he could already do a ton of things the only
additional Powers it looks like he'd obtained at
this new level of his Evolution would be faster
regenerative healing like James good said he
already could regrow his body pretty fast during
the regular movie when he was even smaller greater
durability a massive increase in strength like he
is huge a higher level of chlorokinesis which is
their ability to control other plant life around
him and if it wasn't clear they haven't quite done
this in the Guardians of the Galaxy movies yet
but Gru can also heal other people's normal wounds
but if you had your arm chopped off he couldn't
regrow someone else's arm there is a limit to
that one but like his body can generate healing
chemicals and also at the end of the movie before
he has grown into his Alpha group form when you
hear him say I love you guys that's not meant
to be another Evolution as he's grown like that's
not a new power or anything like that the special
moment James Gunn clarified is that we're meant to
view it as the audience watching the movie having
become part of the guardian's family like we've
been with them for so long now we're part of the
family and we can understand what he's saying
when he says I am Groot just like Peter Quill
rocket in the other Guardians so when Rockets
Guardians team Star-Lord the other characters
that are staying in the Marvel Universe come back
and say like Avengers 5 King Dynasty he'll still
be saying I am Groot it's not like he's going
to be speaking full sentences every time he's
on screen now the I love you guys was just
meant to be a one-off special moment during
the movie there's a joke with the younger
version of Gamora she couldn't understand it
because she wasn't close to Groot the way original
Gamora became part of groot's family so to speak
she keeps joking with all them they're just making
up stuff that he says like you're just making it
all up aren't you of course we know that's not
true James again talked about this all the way
back during the first Guardians movie when it came
out like oh yeah he's speaking normal sentences
it just sounds like he's saying I am Groot the
way they explained that twist in the comics is
a little bit different but there is an Easter egg
for the comic book version the explanation in the
movie with the universal translator that won't
work in the comics the reason why everyone can
only hear I am Groot is because the universal
translators don't work on the Flora Colossus
language so they just bug out and make it sound
like he's only saying I am Groot when in fact he's
speaking normal sentences in his language just
like he does in the movies The Other funny side
note about this too about people dropping f-bombs
in the Guardians of the Galaxy movies James Gunn
revealed that Peter Quill's F-bomb in the movie
was the first spoken F-bomb in a Marvel movie
okay now what open the door he said that he also
joked about this with Kevin feige and even though
Kevin feige didn't try to stop him or anything
like that like they didn't make him remove it
he did tell James Gunn do you want to be known
as the Director who had an F-bomb in his movie
and James Gunn was like oh hell yeah I would love
to be known as the Director that had an F-bomb in
my movie going out in style his last Marvel movie
going out like a boss but the funny thing is if
you've been following all the stuff he's been
saying about the movies behind the scenes he's
been doing it a lot lately the last week because
this is his final Marvel movie but he does stuff
like this after all of his Guardians movies come
out and years ago James Gunn revealed that teenage
group even when he was a little bit younger cursed
all the time he had the phallus mouth interested
on screen nobody like us the audience ever knew it
because you could only hear him Snicker a little
and piss off the other Guardians verbalizing
it as I am Groot and they'd all yell at him
like Hey how dare you group put that thing
away now I don't want to tell you again hey
you got some acorns on you kid ever since
you got a little sap you're a total d-hole
so if you want to get technical Groot was
dropping f-bomb's other expletives even
worse things long before Peter Quill did it's
just that we didn't know it until James Gunn
told us that was happening now the important
difference between the new version of Groot and
the original Groot is that they're not meant to
be the same character the new Groot is meant to
be kind of like the child of the original Groot
which is different in the comics in the Comics
Group just regrows his body from Little twigs and
they have a moment like they did at the end of
the first Guardians movie during the annihilation
Conquest storyline where rocket takes a twig from
the previous group and regrows it and it's just
the same Groot regrown but because MCU Groot now
is the child of the original Groot that's also why
his personality is so different from the original
Groot like this group loves video games they had
a joke about that during the holiday special with
the Game Boy even though he's super huge now he's
Alpha group that will continue like he will still
love to play video games he also seems much more
social than the original group too like he talks
way more he's way more casual with the rest of
the Guardians most of the movie is meant to tell
us Rocket's origin story but they don't tell us
the story of how he met the original Groot James
Gunn actually explained that the plot for the
movie Rocket's origin story was originally part
of a spin-off Rocket and Groot movie that he had
developed way back when the first Guardians of
the Galaxy movie was coming out like I could do
a spin-off movie about the origin of these two
characters coming together and that just evolved
into the plot of the third Guardians of the Galaxy
movie by the time he got to writing that in the
movie we learned that he's a regular raccoon that
the high evolutionary evolves into his current
form cool side Note 2 he's a raccoon from Earth
meaning that he's from Earth just like Peter Quill
so Earth Is His home technically maybe they'll
address that in a future movie or there'll be some
joke about it I don't think he feels like Earth Is
His home though in the comics he originally came
from half world but there is an Easter egg for
half-world as his planet of origin during their
lineup in prison during the first Guardians movie
there's also a bit of an Easter egg for groot's
origin story during that too he's from a planet
called Planet X it seems like the way James Gunn
is explaining this is that rocket escaped from
the high evolutionary then he went to half world
where he continued to grow the rest the way grew
to adulthood then he met the original group they
became friends and then eventually ran into the
other Guardians of the Galaxy and the team formed
during that first movie they might eventually tell
the rest of the backstory for groot's character
too because they don't really get into that
during the movie what happened is that he grew
up as a normal member of the Flora Colossus race
on Planet X he didn't really get along with his
other saplings as they call them like the younger
members of their race eventually he was banished
from his planet for killing another member of his
race protecting another humanoid after that during
Annihilation Conquest in the comics that was the
story where this guardian's roster came together
for the first time but in the comics during that
storyline he was captured in Cree space and
met rocket in his prison they became friends
and that's how they started working together also
joining the Guardians of the Galaxy during that
run the new groot's relationship with rocket is
also a little bit different from the original
groot's relationship with rocket so they've kind
of implied this in all their movies that they've
appeared in the new younger version of Groot even
though he's super huge now kind of views rocket
as his surrogate father the same way that Peter
Quill thought of yondu as his surrogate father
if he thought that scene of everybody getting
snapped at the end of Avengers Infinity war
was sad it gets even sadder because even though we
only hear him say I am Groot as he's being snapped
James Gunn said that what he was really saying was
crying out for his father rocket like he literally
called Rocket his father as he was being snapped
away so obviously he's much bigger now much more
capable of defending himself probably almost as
powerful as say like Adam Warlock or Phyla-Vell
Quasar here but he still thinks of Rocket as his
surrogate follow the way that Peter Quill always
thought of yondu as his surrogate father and in
the comics they also recently tied the origin of
his race to the gardener Elder of the universe
who's meant to be really powerful so they could
always tie that to his backstory in the MCU like
say that the gardener is the character who created
his race the way the high evolutionary created The
Sovereign race and in a bunch of other races James
Gunn said that he did talk to Marvel about the
next place that they'll be using this guardian's
roster and even though this was his last Marvel
movie Marvel would continue to use this team in
other movies even if they might not do guardians
4 but he was also open to another director doing
Guardians 4. like if Edgar Wright came and did
a Guardians of the Galaxy movie right now it
just seems like Avengers 5 King Dynasty is the
next place we'll see this team like at the end
of the movie when it says that tag scene of the
legendary Star-Lord will return they're mostly
focused on star-lord's character he's on Earth so
naturally he will be in Avengers 5 King Dynasty
that's the whole reason why he ends the movie on
Earth in addition to completing his character Arc
but also they want him to be on earth so that he
can be on that next Avengers team that faces the
dynasty of Kings there was a bunch of cool stuff
that happened this week so I'll try to make videos
for everything as quickly as possible I'm working
on a new Daredevil Born Again Punisher video right
now too everyone click here for my full Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 breakdown Easter eggs from the
entire movie and click here for my Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 post credit scene video thank you
so much for watching everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!